it is a bold move by president joe biden
who's been paying his respects to the
war debt but the withdrawal from
afghanistan after 20 long and grueling
years he says
is the right one despite fears that a
resurgent taliban
will come back with a vengeance we
cannot continue the cycle
of extending or expanding our military
presence in afghanistan
hoping to create ideal conditions for
the withdrawal
and expecting a different result i'm now
the fourth
united states president to preside over
american troop presence in afghanistan
two republicans two democrats
i will not pass this responsibility onto
a fifth
the drawdown of troops will start on may
the first nato forces are also ending
their operations
in coordination with the us joe biden
made a campaign promise to end the
countries forever wars
and he is delivering on that but the
white house is also signaling with the
withdrawal
that america's priorities are changing
china
and an increasingly assertive russia as
seen by policymakers here
as the big threat this century
the u.s remained scarred by 9 11 an
attack on its shores
that would set in motion the wars in
afghanistan and iraq
20 years later and joe biden is finding
out as the british did in the 19th
century
and the soviets did in the last why the
country is called the graveyard of
empires
and the cost in blood and treasure is
staggering
two trillion dollars and the lives of
more than 2
400 troops but it's also been
a graveyard of afghans nearly 40
000 civilians have been killed in two
decades of bloodshed
the truth is that afghanistan is a state
dependent on aid and
outside forces without a supply of both
the future looks bleak when you talk
about what's going to happen
regardless of how much fighting there is
and there probably will be
serious fighting the real risk is this
sort of strange structure that grew out
of 20 years of war
is going to implode and with it the
lives of many
afghans failed states well it's a failed
state and it is failing millions
literally of people the date of
september the 11th will remain etched in
the psyche of americans for years to
come
but the end of its operations may be the
beginning of a new nightmare in
afghanistan
one in which any progress made is lost
and there's a return
to the years of civil war alex rossi
sky news washington